here's the idea i'm going to try and
build out a 3d
mmorpg from scratch in javascript
kind of like world of warcraft or really
any of the big ones that are floating
around these days
i'm not going to lie i've got a lot of
problems to figure out here i mean i'm a
graphics guy
i only have the most basic understanding
of networking and so there's a whole
bunch of questions i have
like what's the architecture for one of
these games even look like
how do i deal with lag and that kind of
stuff what language should i use for the
server
if i use javascript node.js or dino or
deno or whatever
what is even the difference between
those so i've kind of got a lot of
things to work through here
and i'll do a bunch of research there's
info and references online for the
architecture
breakdowns on the various approaches to
networking and even suggestions on what
language to use
to start i'll just stick with javascript
and i've chosen to go with socket.io
mostly because it was the first thing
that came up when i googled for a
library
and looking through the site it looks
pretty easy to get things going
this getting started tutorial is
downright trivial so i've just copied
all of this to a set of server and
client files
and when we run this oh well some sort
of cores error actually
doesn't seem like this is a big deal
socket io has a whole section on what to
do here
okay i'm a little ashamed of how long
that took luckily stack overflow saved
my butt at some point so
this is off to a super bad start but at
least we now have the ability to connect
and
communicate between the server and
client let's get a basic scene going
the next step will be to take one of the
three dot js examples from before and
integrate the socket.io code in what i'm
going to do is copy one of the example
projects in
and in the code here i'm just copy
pasting the basic socket i o code in
when we load this up well all we should
see is a small scene with a plane in box
and in the console we should see the
output from the server
nothing crazy or impressive to see here
at least not yet
let's get some stuff moving around we
have our connection established let's
get some players in here
so in the server code what i'm going to
do is whenever a connection is made
we're spawning off a new wrapper around
each player and we'll keep track of all
of them
and the first thing the server sends is
a message of where the other connected
players are
on the client it's pretty similar we
listen to messages from the server
it sends you a list of all the other
players and where they are
so when we load it up the first browser
just sees itself
but if we go and open the second browser
yay we see two boxes
and another box appears in the first
browser i've just quickly attached some
keyboard input to the box
and now we can move it around so we'll
just send that to the server
on the server it'll receive the new
player coordinates and just spam that
out to every other player
and now that gives us two movie boxes
you can see in one window as i move it
around
it moves around in the other window so
win let's make this look a little bit
less sad
we just have these little boxes let's
tighten up the graphics
and we already have a few models from
previous tutorials
so in the code here what i'm going to do
is copy paste the character movement and
loading code
from another tutorial here on the server
i'll just modify the first
message it sends it'll randomly pick
between either the zombie or the guard
when you first connect
when we load that up it looks pretty
sweet we have two players now with
actual models not crappy little boxes
but there's a problem in that the main
character moves around fine
but the other player seems to be idling
internally
my first thought was to just send
whatever state they're in as part of the
transform
which is just an awful solution but
surprisingly works
you can see me moving around and the
other player is also walking and running
and look if i hit the dance button they
dance and it gets mirrored in the other
browser
so hooray for bad solutions let's add
some chat
we practically have an mmorpg already
depending on your definition of
massively
but we're missing some basic
functionality that a lot of mmorpgs have
which is some sort of chat box yeah
that's all that's missing
let's add that so in the code i'm just
throwing together some html
and an input box which will display in
the lower left corner
loading up that test one you can see the
text down here so it's all good
let's make it real back in the code when
you enter some text and hit
enter i just wipe the input element and
then send that to the server
which spams it out to everyone easy
enough
now it works and i can chat with myself
which is pretty cool
and super easy and you can see as i open
up a second browser window and write
something
it also shows up so really cool but
let's move on
let's add some floating names here again
looking at reference footage
in other words world of warcraft
everybody's name floats over their heads
so let's do that this is pretty simple
3.js has this canvas texture element
which is super versatile
i can just draw to a canvas and then 3js
will make that into a texture
then when we create a sprite out of that
and position it over the players
it's all good you can see that everyone
has a name now
it's random since nobody actually has a
name and code but it works
so let's just ignore that for now and
we'll swing back to it at some point
later
so a small check in here we've got a few
things working
just barely but we need an entire world
we need interaction between players we
need
npcs we need a way of supporting all of
this without the server exploding
so there's more than a few to do's here
integrate our
rpg game code a little while ago
i threw together a quick rpg skeleton
which does a lot of things we want
like fighting inventory that kind of
thing
what i'm doing is integrating all of
this into our little networking demo
here
which mostly means that i'm moving a lot
of the networking code into its own
behaviors and disabling anything that
just isn't going to work anymore in the
networking environment
once we load that up well we don't
actually expect to see much
i removed pretty much everything but we
have the characters again
and we have a small world now with a
flat ground and the sky
it was a lot of work for seemingly
nothing but it'll help us move forward
start sending proper state my
understanding of reading about
entity interpolation is that we need to
step the server at some sort of tick
rate
then update all the clients on the
server
i'm changing the architecture a bit we
now have this update loop that runs and
updates all of the clients
doing whatever logic and updates are
necessary and periodically sending a
state update to everyone
on the client i'm just sending
transforms and actions
so that's all we're sending out on the
server the big difference is now
on the client we're going to receive
those updates and instead of just
applying them right away
we're going to save them with a small
delay then gradually apply the updates
interpolating the state valve has a
really great write-up on entity
interpolation here
and i'll leave a link in the description
below but the idea is that you queue
updates from the server and you smoothly
play them back on the client
that means now in the game instead of
them jerkily moving around
they move and turn smoothly which is way
more realistic and fun to watch
we need stuff to die part of what makes
these mmos fun
is the combat so we need to add some
killing in here
our rpg already had the ability to kill
npcs
so we just need to thread that through
in a way that works with the server
i'm kind of thinking when you attack you
send an event to the server which then
broadcasts it to everybody nearby
in code that means that we need to hook
up the attack controller to send an
event to the server
saying we're attacking something and on
the server that event gets queued up and
then
when the tick goes off it just sends up
all the events that occurred since the
last tick
in the client code we interpret those
events in the npc network controller
setting appropriate animations and even
playing effects
loading this up cool we have attacking
watch i can load up a second character
and then i can be a total jerk and just
walk up to them and start attacking for
no reason
just like in real games let's make the
world more worldly
right now it's just a big flat green
plane representing the ground which is
ugly and stupid i have better terrain
work from other videos
notably my terrain generation stuff we
just need to integrate it
that's easy enough dropping the code
into our folder and instantiating it is
trivial
but the problem is that the terrain had
a custom shader
and also see those big ugly seams
everywhere i never did come back and fix
those
i make a lot of empty promises anyway
let's fix those now
well in my recent fog tutorial i showed
you how to hack into 3.js of shaders
we're going to do the same thing here in
the code we're going to intercept the
shader before it's compiled
and we'll inject this chunk of terrain
shader code inside the standard shader
it's a gross ugly hack but look now
the character has a nice shadow which
shows up on the train properly
and also receives the lighting in the
scene now we need to fix these big seams
in the world
something that i've been promising to do
forever there's clever
and less clever ways of approaching the
problem i'll choose the less clever away
since it's easier
if i have a chunk of terrain let's draw
a chunk of terrain like this
a super-duper easy way of fixing the
seams is to just give them a little
skirt around the edges
in the code that means that we just need
to go back into this block of terrain
generation code
and add an extra layer of vertices
around the edge
then add an extra couple of small loops
to go around the edges fixing them up
loading that up we see that well it
actually took a few tries because i
managed to screw this up in a variety of
kind of interesting ways but eventually
this worked out the way i wanted it to
and we got terrain without little
slivers everywhere
the dumb approach works well enough i
can't really see the skirts
if you can then you have better eyes
than i do this world is pretty dead
we've got our world yes but it's dead
there's nothing here
we need some foliage and stuff there's a
cool site i like
quaternious this isn't sponsored or
anything it's just nice stuff and free
anyway there's a bunch of trees clouds
rocks and other junk spread over
a few packages so i took those in code i
just created this scenery controller
object whose job
will be to spawn bits of foliage
everywhere the trick here
is that if i spawn things randomly two
different clients will see different
things
see here i load up two side by side and
notice they don't see the same stuff
everywhere
so we need to spawn these randomly but
deterministically
i'll use a uniform grid to do this it's
kind of like doing poisson disk sampling
except way worse and not similar at all
but it's cheap and easy
i just loop over a grid of nearby points
sample the noise at specific locations
and decide randomly to place something
or not that way when you load up
something on both clients
they see exactly the same thing same
foliage
same orientation everything in exactly
the same spot
let's ditch the zombie in the guard
there's this site
mixamo which has amazing animated
characters which are completely free
so i scrolled around here looking for a
few characters that we could put into
the game
i settled on these two this sorcerer
looking girl maybe i can give her some
cool effects
and this night guy i can give him
different weapons
but there's a problem and there's always
a problem anyway
so miximo exports fbx files and 3.js
imports fbx easy right except
no so you end up with totally botched
characters
sometimes they work like with the zombie
in the guard and other times no
i have no idea why i googled around a
bit
and on don mccurdy's site i found a way
forward
if i import all of these into blender
myself along with the animations
blender can re-export this all as a gltf
properly
so that's what i did i grabbed them one
by one with all the assets
imported them into blender which was
painful since i don't know my way around
blender
but it's worth it look at my working new
characters so
serious and rpg-ish let's add some
monsters now
so same deal we need to browse mixamo
for some free monster models
there's a bunch of cool ones like this
warwick guy or girl or whatever it is
looks strong there's also this zombie
thing
looks kind of like out of a blade movie
took both of these
there's a bit of server work to add one
of these you create an instance of an
entity like the actual players but we
make it slightly differently since
there's no
socket connection i made this new world
ai entity that's basically just a
wrapper around it
and it passes a fake client to reuse the
same code that the player does
when i load this up cool we have this
dude just kind of standing there doing
nothing
so it worked but we want this guy to run
around but there's a few problems
he's standing through the ground and the
server literally has no idea what the
terrain is like
the server and client share no code at
all right now
and node.js has a completely different
style of importing modules than the
browser does
this was a bit of a wild goose chase my
complete and total lack of experience
with node.js was showing pretty strongly
here
but it turns out newer versions can use
the same code
so you just rename everything what dot
mjs and update node
and yay look my guy is standing on the
train the server knows where the terrain
is now make the monsters less stupid
i just want them to follow me around so
i moved the spatial hashgrid code
if you remember that tutorial i moved it
to a shared spot in the server and
client
and added a quick finite state machine
to the ai
it's just a few crude states like just
stand there
see someone and walk towards them attack
etc
like always takes a few tries to get
this right but you can see the
progression here until i
finally worked my way through the bugs
and it followed me around
make a lot more monsters we've got to
start producing monsters like crazy now
that they're working
so i make a quick spawner thingy on the
server to wrap up the spawning code
and just throw a big loop to spawn them
all over the map
that kind of works like i can log in and
see the monsters in my
area but there's a problem like always
i kind of assume the loading code didn't
try to load the actual assets from
scratch each time
but save them no idea why i thought that
but yeah this is super slow to load them
all
so just make one loading interface and
route everything through there
and clone if it's already loaded job
done
way faster also this guy kind of blinks
in and out of existence occasionally
looks like some sort of 3.js bug so i
just disabled frustum cullen
kind of tired of dealing with this let's
add a little bit of polish
i want some cool spell effects like the
big games do
and i made a particle tutorial a while
back so we'll just use that
what i need to do is create a new effect
controller component thingy
and we'll instantiate a particle system
in there binding it to the hands of the
character
i don't have some sort of awesome unity
style ui to make my particles in so
you get whatever i programmed in a few
minutes and again
broken at first but a few bug fixes in
and i finally got a casting fiery spell
thing
so all good last step let's add a login
screen
let's make it so that you can actually
choose your name and log in
so i threw together some really quick
html and that gives us a really basic
screen warcraft zone is certainly cooler
though
so i've taken some inspiration and now
i'll just draw over it really quick
hooray look at that we have a login
screen let's turn on some dramatic music
too
and i can write my own name and log in
now at this point you can
barely tell the whole thing was made by
one guy in a week
and here's the final product we've got a
full-on world here
let me just kind of super-speed run
around a bit and it expands out
thousands of meters in every direction
with no end to the terrain the foliage
or the monsters
well i mean there is an end i can run to
it but yeah whatever this is good enough
this was kind of fun to make i'm not
really sure if i can declare it as
success
as i said at the beginning mmorpgs are
super hard to make and there's so much
more we could add to this
more content quests actual persistence
since i don't save anything but this is
kinda
roughly very roughly resembles one at
least i'll clean the code up and throw
it up on github
so look for it there let me know what
you thought in the comments below
make sure to subscribe and like the
video helps me out a lot
until next time cheers